hello reject nation its Greg outta here
and it's John over here we're gonna
watch the trailer officials trailer
numero dos for bright
okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
we have to
[Laughter]
no way
we were doing so good yeah
[Music]
perhaps I think we should spend our time
just trying to survive this year
cause the soundtrack movie with Will
Smith starring in it directed by David
Ayer the first trailer didn't feel as
much Suicide Squad II as this one does
yeah there's a lot more a little bit
more than the Suicide Squad lines of
what we saw David Ayer previously
produced I feel like he's Crested into a
new section of his career where he makes
David Ayer ask big action fantasy movies
yeah because it's still got that like
gritty cops in the inner cities stuff
going on but then it's got all this
fantasy stuff on the side I'm pretty
drawn to the movie actually up most
likely be watching this probably the day
it comes out I like this trailer to be
honest this trailer made me want good
things for this movie cuz this is a
genre that I am pretty weary of just
because there aren't a lot of great
examples of it working out
Will Smith looks awesome and this and I
like the joel edgerton like God under
all that makeup Will Smith I'm happy to
see him just returning to more of like
what he did with bad boys
it's more like training day Meets Lord
of the Rings but I get more of his
performance from like a bad boys or a
men in black even more of what was cool
about him in Suicide Squad he's got the
attitude back you know and it's an art
not afterwards he was dropping in this
trailer a surprise for a TRO that has
this many f-bombs you don't really see
much violence and I'm thinking it's
David Ayer you're probably getting at
some good violent sincerity something
tells me that on this one he might be
able to strike a much better tone yeah
yeah I mean I still have faith in David
Ayer's competence and talent in rectory
the thing about all the DC movies up
until this point sans Wonder Woman is
you gotta imagine there's a lot going on
behind the scenes that we don't know
about and this looks like there's a good
opportunity for less media appearance I
feel like this is probably doing more
along the lines of what he wanted to
actually do with something like a
Suicide Squad make it a gritty movie
with supernatural elements but also have
the gang survive it seemed like that's
what we wanted to do a Suicide Squad you
didn't get to do that it seems like
that's what he's gonna be able to do
here bring it into a different realm of
fantasy not superhero ask but still have
people with heightened abilities like
alright PD yeah looking like a better
version of RIPD and Will Smith looks
really funny in it
he was cracking me on this is that buddy
cop type of dynamic that he has in those
two movies as well and he's like the
funnier guy I guess the one thing that
concerns me is that this film might be
have a little too much mumbo-jumbo by
the time it all concludes you know yeah
I'm curious as to how the world is gonna
feel whether it's gonna be awkward
having all these elements in it or
whether it's gonna feel you know natural
I'm all for weird and strange yeah I
could really get on board with that but
I don't want to happen is you find out
Will Smith's character is really someone
with a bigger purpose yeah I don't and
it kind of seems like with images or
beginning especially towards the end of
the trailer that it's alluding to that
just a little bit I'm hoping it doesn't
do that that's what I mean by
mumbo-jumbo I'm like just keep him he's
just a human and he has his orc buddy
and now he has to work together to solve
this case and protect the wand and then
you could probably get like sequels out
of this as Will Smith's always looking
for a franchise you know I feel like
Netflix more often than not has pretty
good judgment the fact that they jump
behind this is a positive for me well
the fact that Will Smith is jumping
behind it because this dude he you know
he normally doesn't do something unless
he gets a fat paycheck so he must have a
real big faith in who David Ayer is as a
director and what this project actually
is to and allows them to do something
different like still do the Will Smith
stamp of being a different type of movie
something were more accustomed to seeing
him do this is something that I like to
see Netflix take advantage of because I
can't think of something that they've
done it's a live action sci-fi piece not
least this it seem like they have the
budget to be able to go down the path to
do something like this because like when
I see this trailer trailer I'm like ah I
imagine this would be hard to get a
worldwide release yeah and perform well
at the box office is supposed to put it
on Netflix is a great choice but yeah at
the end of the day - his chemistry with
a Joel Edgerton that that just looks
really solid this trailer charmed me so
much more than I thought it was gonna be
yeah just them going back and forth that
whole thing about like how she make it
gunfight on it and apparently they have
Shrek in this world no one dishes out
like Will Smith your Shrek looking at no
one can deliver a line like that quite
the way Will Smith can well in terms of
the music you know they're saying like
get the album is that gonna be David
Ayers new thing well I'm hoping it's not
because you know there was way too much
soundtrack in Suicide Squad it got so
I'm hoping he doesn't make another like
a lot of music video stuff in this movie
as well or just a lot of craziness the
soundtracks I hope it's a lot more
composed in a specific tone that he's
going for here and it's like a nice
variety but it's all still in tune with
the majority of the film and it's not
just all over the place maybe this is
just my brain doing its thing but I feel
like this is kind of an opportunity to
improve upon what happened with suicides
go out in every conceivable ways you
know if he can take this and use his
music choices in a really cool way you
know when it's not yeah so intrusive
like it wasn't Suicide Squad hey I mean
more power to you more power to you a or
alright guys well what do you think of
the trailer for bright are you excited
for Will Smith to be in this r-rated
flick do you think David aider was the
best thing in the world tell me how much
you love furious subscribe to the real
rage X click that notification bell you
can follow us on social media and make
sure to check out our patreon become a
patron eject today people a lot of fun
perks over there